today we're going to be looking at item
number scp-239 object class Keter
special containment procedures scp-239
is to be kept within a one room cell
furnished with one bed one EKG machine
and one IV to be filled with a
pentobarbital mixed with to be refilled
daily under no circumstances is scp-239
to be removed from her containment area
at any given time the walls of the cell
are to be coated in a Teleca lead alloy
only class 2 personnel are allowed any
contact with scp-239 at any time all
personnel guarding scp-239 s containment
area are to be equipped with Teleco
headgear the subjects proper name is
something I'm gonna leave to a
text-to-speech program see who doses
demo started under absolutely no
condition should the subject ever be
awakened any personnel found attempting
to awaken the subject will be
immediately terminated description
scp-239 appears to be an 8 year old girl
1 meter in height and 20 kilograms in
weight subject has shoulder-length blond
hair upon closer inspection the subjects
eyes shimmer a gray green shade subject
seems to emit a previously undiscovered
form of radiation which has been named
these waves seem to be harmless in low
concentrations but in higher
concentrations they could breakdown
matter on a subatomic level scp-239
seemingly has the ability to do whatever
she expresses a will to do but simply
the subject can do anything that she
truly wants to do on a basal
psychological level as long as she is
conscious
fortunately she only seems to be able to
affect herself and her immediate
surroundings
therefore if she can see it she can
change it it would not be the most
prudent course of action however to try
to test how powerful she can be she
seems to be able to create an effect
living matter for example when a d-class
personnel accidentally caused her harm
she simply wished him away fortunately
when the subject was made to feel guilty
for what she had done she wished him
back scp-239 self-preservation instinct
makes her virtually invincible while
he's conscious subject skin cannot be
punctured by anything excepting SCP 148
as a method of controlling the subjects
ability she has been told that she is a
witch this besides improving morale
greatly makes her believe that she is
unable to use her abilities outside of a
pre-approved list of spells given to her
by the foundation this will hopefully
prevent any and all attempted escapes
however the subject is to be kept calm
at all times to prevent any subconscious
wish of harm to herself or others
origin scp-239 came to the attention of
the foundation very soon after her birth
approximately three hours after the
subjects birth hospital was destroyed by
an unexplained explosion the press was
informed that it was due to a gas leak
SCP teams were dispatched shortly to
search the site for any abnormalities
the only living person they were able to
locate was scp-239 for the next eight
years the subject was raised under SCP
care as of 20 subjects is to be kept in
a medically induced coma until further
notice this decision was made by
scp-239 is permanently contained inside
17 note from dr. dated the 26th of
December 2004 who the hell thought it
will be a good idea to tell her about
Santa Claus and then tell her that it
was just a story now we have another
potential SCP to deal with but we can't
catch him because he is quote magic
dr. ade clefts report my analysis of the
situation has led me to the conclusion
that scp-239 is an unacceptable
containment and security risk although
several proposals have been made re
using her for containing other scps
the example of scp-956 of overestimating
the foundation's ability to control s
cps with reality altering powers I would
therefore like to make the following
proposal a piercing implement will be
constructed of scp-144 Belov penetrating
scp-239 s otherwise impenetrable skin
this tool will be used to kill scp-239
while she is asleep and her powers are
neutralized because of the danger of
scp-239 awakening and resisting
termination it is my recommendation that
the selective operative carry scp-668 as
well in order to minimize complications
one of the dangers of this procedure is
the possibility that scp-239 will awaken
and perceive the operative as a friend
or a quote good person in quote thus
changing reality to match it is for this
reason that I would like to volunteer to
carry out the procedure personally a
review of my personnel file should
indicate that month should allow me to
carry out the operation even after a
reality shift of this nature
Clell
oh man dr. clef is a weirdo
you